You have received this medicine from
Nursing student, I think it is necessary to have nursing students
Able to do this, in case I was you
The patient who receives the medicine
So let's solve it
I think the issue of transforming this unit is interesting
For anyone who wants to practice unit conversion
If the question is that we have a doctor
This doctor has requested x
This is the dose required by doctors
They say 5 milligrams per pound of patient weight - will
Write per pound of patient weight - every 12 hours
This is what we are supposed to do
But giving us the medicine - it's not just
Nuggets and milligrams
It is even a treat
There is a certain amount of fines per milliliter
Our treatment
It is dissolved with water
If this is our medicine supply x
We have 0.9 - I write 0 in front
My wife, a doctor, says it's necessary to write
Zero in front of the decimal point
We have 0.9 g / ml of treatment
If you want to take 1 ml of treatment
And give it to someone, I really give it
0.9 grams of this medicine
The latest information that we have been given is that
The patient - his weight - probably should say his mass
Because the kilogram expresses the mass, but we recognize the idea
The patient's weight is 72.2 kg
If there is a bunch of interesting stuff here
We have to find the dose in milliliters
And we have - in fact, not told you
the question
The question is, how many ml of medicine
Should we give the patient at each dose?
If ml of medication per dose
this is the question
There is a set of things
We have to move from milligram to gram
Then turn it into milliliters
We were then told each pound, but we gave later
The patient's weight, or mass, is the kilogram
So we have to make some conversions here
No doubt I can appreciate how this could be
Hard and perhaps confusing
So let's solve it step by step
If the first thing is interesting - and this
Something you probably need to know, or maybe you
Write it on paper, or maybe you have a calculator
Doing this - is how to convert a kilogram to a pound
It is good to know in general, if you are turning
Between the metric and English systems
If 1 kilogram equals approximately 2.2 pounds
Not exactly, but that's a good approximation
And one pound - if you put 1 above it - one pound
Roughly equal to 0.45 kg
We will put this in a box
This is the only type of external conversion information
Which we will need to resolve this issue
Everything else we'll need is his calculator, if that does not
We want to spend a lot of time in the account
If the first thing
Let's find the dose of medication per kilogram
This per pound, in fact we do not need
To know every 12 hours
Because we were told, how many milliliters of medicine
Keep in each dose?
The dose will be in every 12 hours
If you know - every 12 hours is a
Additional information--
If we want to find these 5 milligrams per pound
How do we convert this to milligram / kg?
If we put 5 - I'll write it here in purple -
5 mg / lbs
And then we will convert this per kilogram
If we can multiply this by the number of pounds per
Kg - I will write it in yellow - × this
Information at the top
I x 2.2 lbs / kg
If you feel a bit of confusion - learn, how you know
Would you hit 2.2 instead of dividing it at 2.2?
This is equivalent to multiplying by 0.5
You can pay attention to units
Note, I have written 2.2 lb / kg
2.2 lbs per 1 kg
As you know this will succeed, because we have a pound in
Rugs and we have a pound in place
This is called dimensional analysis
If you feel confused about these things - I think
When you get enough exercise, you will find that it does not
You have to pay close attention to him
But at first, when you begin to solve, in order
Make sure you do not hit or divide the wrong thing
Just make sure the dimensions have been deleted
Lb in rugs, and pound in the place
So let's do it
The pound in the rugs, and the pound in the square are deleted
We hit 5 x 2.2
This equals - let us see
5 × 2 = 10
5 × 0.2 = 1
If this equals 11
Then we have milligrams in rugs
11 mg / kg
If we have converted the dose information to
Metric metric system
This was a mixture between the metric system
The former English system
Now let's see what we can do
Well, let's see if we can get it in terms of how much
Ml we have to prepare for each pound
If again, we want this - well, actually, let's
We turn to love first
Because we have milligrams here
We have a gram here at the top
So let's see if we can turn this thing into a gram
As we did previously, we want to get milligram
In the place
I'll do this orange
We want to get milligrams in place and want
Love in the rugs
Why did you say that?
Because I want to delete this and this
I want to get the gram in the rugs
How many grams per milligram?
You can think about this
There is one gram per 1000 milligrams
Or 1000 milligrams per gram
And you beat him
If the milligrams are deleted with milligrams, then
We get - this is equal to 11/1000 g / kg
If we now have everything in unity, we want it
In milliliters
The question is, how many milliliters of
Medication for each dose?
Let me down here on this line
We got this result
We have 11/1000 - I do not want to swear now - Gram
Of the drug x / kg
This is - we are rewriting
This dose is known in different units
Let's see how many doses we want per kilogram
If I delete the gram from here and get
On the miller here
Until the gram is deleted, you must get the
Gram in the denominator and millimeter in rugs
If at one dose, how many grams per milliliter?
Well, we've been told
It has 0.9 g / mL
Or per 1 ml, there is 0.9 grams
Notice, I've taken that upside down
Because we want milliliters in rugs, and grams in
Place, and thus delete them
Now let's do this beating
If the gram is deleted
We have milliliters / kg
And then hit
11 / 1,000 x 1 / 0.9
I'll keep - let me write this way
This becomes 11 / 1,000 × 0.9 milliliters of
Medicine / kg
We've got this in advance
This per kilogram of patient weight
Finally, we were asked how many kilograms
The patient weighs
If let's do another hit, then we can
Extract the calculator and we run all the calculations at once
Let's hit this b - we want to know how much
Ml per patient
We want to delete the kilogram
If we want a kilogram / patient
We are now talking about this particular patient
Not every patient will have the same
Kg
But if we do, the kilogram will be removed
And we have a milliliter / patient - milliliters of
The medication for each patient - exactly what we want
We want 1 ml of medication per dose per patient
But everything we assumed was for each dose
So how many kilograms does the patient weigh?
Well, there are 72.2 kg / patient
This is what the patient weighs
If we do this last beating
We finish
If the answer - and these two things will be deleted -
If the final answer is 11 x 72.2
100 100 × - in fact, that is 100 × 0.9
It is easy to find the outcome of their multiplication
This equals 900
900 900 ml / patient
Or we can tell the ml / dose
As you like
Per dose per patient
Let us extract the calculator and do this
If we have 11 × 72.2 = 799, 900 900
= 0.88 - Well, we can get closer
0.889
I hope the doctor does not mind
If this equals - I will write it in a beautiful color--
0.889 ml of medication per dose
This is what we will give every 12 hours
If asked, how many milliliters
For a treatment that lasts for Leoman?
We have to say, there are 24 hours
We will beat it by 4
But those 12 hours were additional information on this issue
But anyway, I wish this presentation was helpful, I will ensure that
Any nurse in the future will give me
The right dose
I hope the doctor will also get the right dose of medication to start
Otherwise, everything will be useless
In any case